Michael Myers isn't the only one cutting
deep from Human wall hangings to glasses
of chocolate milk Halloween ends is
filled with easy to miss details and
Easter eggs warning spoilers ahead
in the movie's tragic and terrifying
opening the hopeful prospective college
student Corey Cunningham babysits local
had him filled child Jeremy Allen before
the horror begins Croy and Jeremy are
hanging out and having a good time it's
Halloween
we're gonna have a good time tonight
against the wishes of the Allens Croy is
being a little LAX and letting Jeremy
watch scary movies with him on that
Halloween night it's John Carpenters the
thing not only is the scene of these two
watching the thing an obvious nod to
Carpenter director of the thing and the
original Halloween but it has another
layer to it as well in the 1978
Halloween there is a scene of Lori and
the kid she is looking after watching
the thing of course a young watching
Carpenter's 1982 Masterpiece since he
hadn't made it yet the movie shown in
the original was 1951's the thing from
another world which Carpenter adapted
and reimagined for the 80s pretty
fitting considering the new Halloween
Trilogy is also a reimagining of the
Michael Myers story
Corey Cunningham becomes an outcast
after the night he accidentally kills
Jeremy Allen on the nights of the
accident Corey even had a chance to
drink a beer but Ops for chocolate milk
to accompany his dessert ultimately he
never got a chance to drink the milk
years later he buys chocolate milk at a
gas station afterward a group of teens
asked him to buy them beer once again
bringing Corey's drink of choice into
question but why exactly is chocolate
milk important to Halloween ends there
are a couple of themes I could tie into
why Corey drinks chocolate milk for one
it makes him different from others being
forcing his feeling of being an outcast
but his taste for chocolate milk a drink
usually associated with children is the
important part here this shows us on the
inside he is still more of a child than
he is an adult Corey is a scared kid who
never had a chance to grow up and
Michael Myers Praise on this to unleash
his evil since this is Halloween ends
the story of Lori and Michael
appropriately comes to a conclusion as
as such the movie pays appropriate so
much to where the story began one visual
callback that works on multiple levels
is just one of many references to John
Carpenter's low budget 1978 horror
classic a moment where Corey Cunningham
imitates Michael Myers Corey becomes a
sort of disciple of Michael enacting
murders in Haddonfield after a chance
meeting with Michael and the sewers but
the earliest visual hints that Corey is
going down the Stark path is when he
imitates the slasher villain peeking out
from behind the bush eagle-eyed fans of
the original Halloween will recognize
this as a reference to an early shot in
that film of Michael Myers in the exact
same position it's one of the first
glimpses we get of the character as Lori
walks down the sidewalk on an otherwise
completely normal full day the shot of
Michael peeking out from behind the
Hedge has become an iconic image from
the very first movie in the series
Sandra Dickerson is a minor character
who winds up Surviving all three modern
Halloween movies there was some
speculation over whether or not Sandra
had died in the scene where Michael
attacked her and her husband in
Halloween kills in that film Sandra gets
one of the most grotesque painful
encounters with Michael Myers watching
him attack and kill her husband and
standing in Terror as he puts a tube
light in her neck now when Halloween
ends we see she has survived butt has
been rendered disabled by Michael's
attack and is in a wheelchair in one
scene Sandra's friend Stacy confronts
Lori in a parking lot and blames her for
her friend's condition and the death of
Sandra's husband later when the town is
carrying Michael to his final resting
place we get a brief shot showing us
that Sandra is still around she survived
the events of Halloween ends making her
one of the lucky few throughout the
franchise to survive an encounter with
Michael Myers a great little trick in
scary movies is when the slasher or
Monster is lurking in the background of
a shot almost imperceptible terrifying
if done right this trick can frighten
and foreshadow future events for those
who notice it can also add re-watch
value for anyone who missed it the first
time when it's pulled off and Halloween
ends it also has a deeper meaning since
this is a trout the series uses
constantly with Michael Myers in one
sequence Corey laws a cop who used to
date Alison to Michael Myers hiding
place in a sewer underneath haddenfield
when Halloween ends first pulls this
trick you see Michael in the background
foreshadowing the man's fate however in
a similar shot almost immediately after
the first we now see Corey lurking in
the background of the shot in the same
way it's another hint of ways Arc is
going and the similarities he is
developing with Michael
me how to do it every slasher movie
needs a character who exists just for
the purpose of being senselessly
murdered that appears to be the purpose
of nurse Deb Alison's annoying co-worker
in Halloween ends when it's shown that
she is sleeping with their boss Dr
Mathis which is why Deb received a
promotion over Alison Michael Myers and
his Protege show up for some good
old-fashioned slushing well Mathis has
taken care of by Corey outside Deb is
trapped inside the house with Michael
when she is killed Michael pins her to
the wall that's a direct callback to a
Kill from the 1978 original in Halloween
Michael kills Bob by stabbing him and
pinning him to a cabinet with a kitchen
knife Deb meets a similar face albeit
stabbed in a different place Halloween
ends even puts a cherry on top by having
Michael childishly [ __ ] his head to the
side in Wonder or curiosity the same way
he does in the original
in the original Halloween during their
first encounter Michael slashes Laurie
on the arm which causes her to stumble
and fall over the banister on the top
floor of the Wallace house bleeding and
dizzy from the fall Laurie barely
manages to escape but Halloween ends
reverses the roles and changes the
outcome in the finale of David Gordon
Green's Trilogy it's Corey Who falls
over the stairway banister he is dressed
at this point in full Michael Myers
attire after stealing the mask at the
end of the movie Laurie fakes her own
suicide to lower Corey to her then she
reveals her trap and shoots Corey
sending him over the banister of her
house a shot of him falling Echoes
Lori's fall in the original but this
time the roles are reversed even if
Corey is not actually Michael the visual
imagery of him dressed as Michael Myers
serves as a role reversal for these
characters showing how much Laurie has
grown since the 1978 Halloween
one of Laurie's biggest moments of
victory in John Carpenter's Halloween is
when she stabs a knitting needle into
Michael Myer's neck after he breaks into
the Doyle home after she stabs him he
goes down for a brief moment
incapacitated viewers at the time surely
thought maybe he was dead as Halloween
fans these days though he was just
resting up for round two in another
reversal of Laurie and Michael's roles
as predator and prey it is not Michael
who gets stabbed on Halloween ends
eventually references the knitting
needle scene during the final scuffle in
Lori's home Michael grabs a knitting
needle and stabs Laurie maybe it's
payback from over 40 years ago of course
maybe Michael is just looking for the
most convenient way to kill his rival
regardless of why it happens this moment
is a fun Twist on a cool bag that would
otherwise be a bit too obvious
if you watched Stephen Gordon Green's
2018 Halloween you may remember Julian
he is also known as the hardest kid in
the world to babysit a hilarious
addition to Halloween is that Julia
managed to survive an attack by Michael
Myers his babysitter Vicky and her
boyfriend were not as lucky though
babysitters rally are
there Julian was confirmed to have
survived Maya's Killing Spree in
Halloween but he doesn't show up in
Halloween ends until one of the final
scenes in that scene the movie confirms
that Sandra lived and shows other minor
characters from the trilogy like Lindsay
Wallace getting their Vengeance on
Michael in this Montage of the people of
Haddonfield accompanying Laurie in A
procession we get a glimpse of Julian
just knowing he survived all the
horrible nights in Haddonfield is enough
to warm our hearts pumpkins and pumpkin
pie are pretty Universal symbols for
fall and especially the Halloween season
the same can be said of the Halloween
movies pumpkins are often a symbol of
the series as well appearing in the
opening credit sequences of all the
David Gordon green movies as an Omar
City opening credits of John Carpenter's
original film this pumpkin imagery comes
full circle at the end early on in the
movie Laurie Burns a pie she tells
Alison she's trying to bake her a
pumpkin pie because it is her favorite
dessert during this time of year after
all the stress of Michael's final
Killing Spree a serial killer is
supposedly dead and disposed of and we
see a period of Peace in Haddonfield
Alison recovers from the trauma and
prepares to begin her Life Anew in the
background of the shots it's a delicious
looking slice of pumpkin pie A fitting
bit of closure to her terrifying story
[Music]